the vatican says that pope francis would
be willing to facilitate dialogue to
help stop the war in ukraine a large
majority of the ukrainian population
identifies as orthodox christian and
while their religious leaders have
publicly condemned the invasion recent
statements by the head of the orthodox
church russian patriarch kirill openly
supported moscow's invasion this has
splintered the worldwide orthodox church
and is raising fears of religious strife
it's 2020 and around 50 kilometers from
moscow a cathedral is being inaugurated
in honour of the armed forces
a sign of how tightly entwined orthodox
christianity and politics are in russia
the influence of the orthodox church
leader is hard to underestimate
moscow's patriarch kirill has made no
bones about where his loyalty lies
he's spoken of russia's opponents as
evil forces
portraying ukraine as a nation
succumbing to what he calls sinful
western practices
such as gay pride parades
in ukraine some 30 million orthodox
christians are split between a
self-governing church and the ukrainian
orthodox church which is part of the
moscow patriarchate
but since the invasion the rival leaders
have been united in their condemnation
of russia
with some churches left not even able to
provide a sanctuary from the assault
many clerics in ukraine are now joining
calls for a complete split from the
moscow church
and while karil preaches justification
ukraine's four and a half million
catholics are looking to the head of
their church to wage peace
but while pope francis has called it a
war which sows death destruction and
misery
he has neither named vladimir putin as
the aggressor
nor appealed to carrill to intervene on
the side of peace
i'm not joining the studio by dws
religious affairs analyst martin martin
religion has been sort of a bit of an
underexposed side of this this conflict
many people have been asking themselves
why is putin doing all this
um how important is
faith for putin's war
i think that for the war itself religion
plays actually a pretty important role
it's very difficult to gauge how
important is for putin or how sincere he
might be in his religious commitments
but there is a very long history
uh in in russia of essentially
recruiting political center religious
sentiments of the among the population
in order to support political crusades
and
the proximity of the orthodox church
particularly the muskevite branch arcade
to the kremlin has been essential for
putin to actually rally the population
behind the war effort so
in a sense it's not really just a
theological matter but the church
represents a very strong cultural
position which is very conservative very
reactionary and sees basically the
kremlin as a very capable defender of
those social and cultural positions
ukraine is important for the orthodox uh
church briefly explain why very much so
because the print the the the process of
conversion of of rules or the process of
conversion of the slavic world really to
some degree starts in ukraine uh coming
from the south coming from greek
orthodox churches cappadocia and turkey
but it's really uh it's really the
ukraine what opens so to say
the gates of the slavic word
christianity
for the russians the ukrainian church is
actually very important and it has been
one that has been very close to the
white patch arcade but obviously kirill
is also a very divisive figure now for
really quite a long time so he has
actually
managed over the last couple of years to
break relations
to several of his orthodox peers
so could we regard uh kiev as the is the
founding place really of the russian
orthodox church isn't it and could we
regard this war as putin's war to
reclaim the jerusalem if you will of the
orthodox church look there is absolutely
no doubt in my mind at least following
sort of the cycle the cycle of news and
explanations that there is a very strong
messianic uh you know message uh being
being essentially you know deployed it's
not really coming across when you look
at politicians and when you listen to
the news but it's certainly
there when you actually start to hear
what people are saying different
parishes in different churches and so on
it's obvious that the split of the
ukrainian church which now has actually
three-way split
is seen as basically a runaway a runaway
congregation for the church in moscow
but i think that it's also the case that
the proximity of orthodoxy with russian
sentiments of identity
tend to actually look at ukraine as
something that is essentially an
escaping child of the of the bruce mead
of the russian ruski made of the russian
uh uh
not empire but certainly imperium sort
of the the space of influence
our religious affairs responded martin
guck there thank you martin you're
welcome
you